one of the top things that I get asked
about is Auto ml in this two-part video
let's try using Auto ml vision to build
and deploy a machine learning model that
recognizes different types of chairs
along with a few other items sprinkled
in for good measure we're doing it all
from the raw data collection all the way
to serving the model everything in
between
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we'll explore Auto
ml vision currently in alpha and get our
data into the right format as an input
in part two we'll use this data to build
a model to detect what style of chair is
in a picture one of the things that
makes Auto ml so compelling is having a
custom model existing models and
services like the vision API have no
problem recognizing that these pictures
have chairs in them but what if you made
your own chairs and you needed a way to
catalog the various brands of different
chairs in your inventory wouldn't it be
nice to be able to use a custom vision
API sub speak which recognizes your
particular chairs that's what we're
going to try to do with Auto ml vision
Auto ml vision takes as an input lots
and lots of labelled photos so get your
camera out and start snapping pictures
how many pictures you ask well ideally
you'd have hundreds of pictures project
it would be good and then once you get
tired of clicking that shutter option
perhaps you'll try doing what I did to
get lots and lots of pictures to make it
easier to capture data for Auto ml I
chose to gather my training data by
capturing videos of the chairs and then
using the tool ffmpeg to extract out
those frames I've gone out over to the
Google Sunnyvale campus
I took some videos of over a variety of
different outdoor chairs I'll also took
some video of the tables or position
around as well as a bike just to make
things a little more
interesting let's take a look at some of
that footage now here we have some
chairs of different shapes styles and
colors
no video is greater than 30 seconds in
length and we have a short clip of a
table and another of a bike that's the
data that we will be working with the
end it states that we want is a CSV file
that has one row per image and two
columns the first for the location of
the image in Google Cloud storage and
the second for the label like red chair
or table or blue chair to make it easier
to organize I placed each video in its
own folder so then we can run ffmpeg on
each video file in turn within those
folders that way once the frames are
extracted out you'll have one folder per
label filled with images of just that
label this is a handy way to organize
your images and data and it's simpler
than having one massive folder of all
the images intermingled next we can
upload the images to Google Cloud
storage using gsutil replicating our
folder structure of one folder per label
now it's time to get to work creating a
CSV file that lists the path and label
for each image I wanted to include in my
data set now there's lots of ways to
accomplish this but I chose to spin up a
local Jupiter notebook and create a
panda's data frame that gets exported as
a CSV file let's walk through that code
now ok so here we are in our Jupiter
notebook and I've imported OS and pandas
so we can work with the file system and
load up pandas that we can use that to
export our CSV I've listed out all the
folders that I and want to use to pull
in the data and I've listed this out
here explicitly because perhaps in a
different scenario I might choose to use
just a subset of these folders to create
a different training set so then we have
a setup here to create a dictionary of
our folder name and then our mapping to
an array of all of our files for that
folder and so
do that first I'm gonna create an array
of arrays of just all of those file
names each in our array is all the file
names of one folder and the outer array
is just for each folder so here we have
we're listing through all the files in a
folder so our data folders here and
we'll wrap that in an array so that we
can capture that and so we can see here
I've printed a sample of one value one
image from each of the folders and we
can see that they're all different so we
look looks like we're in good shape so
we can take those to our folder names
and all our file names and zip them
together pass them to create a
dictionary using that and our base
Google Cloud storage path we can glue
these two together because we want to
prepend the GCS or Google Cloud storage
path in the final output so what we want
is something like this where we have a
Google Cloud storage directory path with
all the way out to the dot jpg name and
then a comma and then the name of the
label so in this case maybe we have a
comma and then chair black like so and
so to do that we'll loop over the entire
dictionary and for each file in the
array of file names in that dictionary
we will put together the base Google
cloud platform
along with the folder name and file name
you know as well as that label so now we
what we have with us here is an array of
pairs each pair has that path and the
label okay so we can take this array and
just pass it straight into a data frame
pandas accepts that format to create new
data frames from scratch and our data
frame looks exactly as we expect we've
got all our paths and all our labels now
we're ready to export to CSV in this
particular case we want to export such
that we use index equals false and
header equals false this is important
and can really trip you up if you forget
to do this because if you leave the
defaults which are index
true and header' true the outputted CSV
file will have a header row of 0 and 1
and moreover it will have an index
column that comes before everything else
which is just going to be your 0 1 2 3 4
5 so we don't want any of that we just
want the path to the file and a label
and nothing else so we use index false
and header false so if you organized
your folder structure the same way that
I have mine you can take this notebook
and with a couple of minimal changes
adapt it for your use case as well so
I'll definitely publish this notebook
and link to that down below in the video
description alright so now we have a CSV
file describing the location and label
for all the images in our data set we're
ready to train our model join me in part
two of this episode and we'll see just
how well this model can perform thanks
for watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it hit
that like button down below and be sure
to subscribe to get all the latest
updates right when they come out and
while you head over to part 2 of this
video I'm gonna eat this Apple